dans les locaux de l'inrap à dijon
l'histoire s'étire sur des dizaines de
mètres dans des centaines de caisses en
quelques millions de fragments parfois
de quelques millimètres seulement
c'est là que sont venus se ranger les
vestiges du site archéologique de
l'hôpital un quartier qui depuis le 11e
siècle a toujours été un lieu de forte
activité sur les quais aux poissons de
louche mais aussi de grands passages
entre les murs de l'hôpital
les fouilles ont permis de matérialiser
donc de voir un peu de caractériser
toute la vie de attend ce faubourg donc
là aussi bien avec des objets qui fait
de la vaisselle qui est là le fossile de
plus résistant le plus répandu en
archéologie mais également des objets
comme des médailles et des enseignes de
pèlerinage qui documente en fait la vie
des pèlerins qui passait à l'hôpital de
dijon
cette vaisselle du milieu du xviie
appartenait sans doute aux commandeurs
de l'hôpital cette pierre était celle
des fondations des quais de louche ou se
développa une importante activité autour
du poisson
cette pipe et cette cafetière témoigne
de l'arrivée de nouveaux produits qu'ils
allaient rencontrer un certain succès le
tabac et le café le dernier l'objet en
gros retrouver la scène voiture d'enfant
en plastique
donc on a une grande palette d'objets on
va du tessons de poterie du 11e siècle
jusqu'à un jouet d'enfant perdu vers
1968 rien au début des années 70
simplement parce que le bitume est venue
recouvrir un bras de l'ouche et qu'il ne
s'enfonce pas grand chose dans le
goudron d'un parking maintenant c'est à
un nouveau site décrire sa page
d'histoire
une partie des vestiges retrouvés
pourraient d'ailleurs être exposés à la
cité de la gastronomie ce sera toujours
mieux que d'être restés enfouis par
dessous ses fondations